name one couple's activity that wouldn't
be more fun with your boss there welcome
to sensual food tasting the art of
feeding your lover I feel like I don't
belong here since the rejection of great
sadness has enveloped me I kept
expecting this dark feeling to pass but
it's only gotten worse not getting the
job you want stinks in first grade I was
passed over for line leader and I'm
still pissed Kyle D's lines had curves
and gaps and cutting Galore it was a
freaking Carnival yeah what's a line
leader it's not just that I didn't get
the job it's that John Kelly did he's
already released a memo detailing his
Vigilant policing initiative it's
essentially a return to stop and frisk
choosing him is a betrayal of everything
I stand for you feel the same way about
Kyle D I tried to suck it up and go back
to work I put on my uniform and got in
my car next thing I knew I was on a
plane to Mexico didn't even pack a bag I
bought a bundle of novelty shirts at a
nearby gift shop this one says what's up
beaches set of for human reasons
but you hate humor well I'm a joke now
so
it suits me okay but how did you end up
here in Mexico at the exact same tiny
Resort as us Sheila's been talking about
this place for years
I had no idea you'd be here you know
what it's fine sir a lot of people go on
their honeymoon with their boss nope I
thought if I said it out loud I would
normalize it but it's weird it's gonna
be okay how long are you staying sir
just until I get my head right but don't
worry I'll steer clear of YouTube you
won't even know I'm here this place is
so romantic yeah and so
intimate don't worry I'm not listening
to you I'm just thinking about how this
sea bass is cold but not as cold and
cruel as the hands of Fate that have
thrust my entire life Into Darkness
ah damn it I just ordered the sea bass
[Music]
on our butts
not on mine my butt Stones keep falling
off because I'm so tense about Hope
being here and ruining everything hasn't
been that bad really
oops sorry can't even float right
just push me away everyone else does
it's not great but as long as we stay in
here we're safe we're all to Santiago
I'm in your room what how patio door was
open I pushed through the Hedge tell me
what is it about me that screams Loser
yeah you know we're kind of in the
middle of getting massages right now sir
oh how thoughtless of me I'll get down
here so you can see my face oh no hello
the question was what is it about me
that screams
loser
Halloween
it's Heist time
you get a head start on Heist prep good
luck I'm already dressed well I'm also
dressed and I made breakfast wait where
are my eggs in my belly yeah now get a
move on it's Heist time I love Halloween
I love the way the mud revitalizes your
skin and I love how it masks my shame I
am loving this
this is actually quite Pleasant you know
when you invited me to join you today I
was skeptical I had been sitting by the
pool contentedly watching a bee struggle
to avoid drowning and thinking to myself
how I am like that beat man I hope it
survived we can't afford to lose any
more bees they didn't the point is I'm
glad you invited me into your frivolous
activities you helped me to remember
there's more to life at the NYPD wow
that's great to hear sir I feel a lot
better I think I may be heading home
unless you need a third for tonight's
activities sensual Pottery I think we're
good what he's ordering us to break up
look we can deal with this we just need
a new plan I got it we lie tell him we
broke up and then date in secret great
and you'd be okay lying to your captain
okay new plan Captain Holt is here today
yes genius he loves us and he's got tons
of sway in the department he'll tell the
vulture to back down yeah he'll be all
vulture I must insist that you desist I
really think this is gonna work also if
you ever want to bust out that whole
impression at home I'd be okay with that
oh
okay duly noted super disturbing but I'm
definitely gonna do it
hello is that Mr McLean I hear
someone's about to
oh
it's an old dear because he's gonna wait
are you dressed like Bonnie Bedelia and
die hard I am for sexy reasons oh boy
why is he here because he's quitting the
force so I brought him here to convince
him not to but obviously that is not
important anymore all right Captain it's
been a good run thank you for teaching
me the importance of a tie in the
workplace and the doors right over here
wait
you're quitting yes I am no you're not
we're keeping you right here how are you
going to do that physically restraining
me great idea is there anything in
Charles's box of nightmares that could
be used to tie a Pulte
yes literally everything in here could
be used to tie up a person I'm so sorry
I brought Hulk back here I had no idea
you were doing this whole die hard thing
man you really got the hair exactly
right did you contact the onset hair
stylist Paul Abba school no it's a week
oh that's cool too so here's what I'm
thinking we let hold go I have sex with
Holly General but hotter the squad
handles the captain or disbands whatever
we have sex again okay stop suggesting
that we need to stay focused right it's
fragile we need to be gentle away just
follow my lead with pleasure I love the
view I'm sorry this outfit is driving me
insane hello sir sorry again for tying
you spread eagle on the bed apology not
accepted look I know you're upset but
this isn't your last chance to become
commissioner John Kelly's old he's not
going to be in office forever true but
he'll just be replaced by another
mediocre old white man nothing will ever
change all right well what about all
your goals for the nine nine you still
have so much left to accomplish strong
I've accomplished everything that I set
out to do I wanted to reduce crime and I
did there's no crime in Brooklyn anymore
it seems like a bit of a stretch what
about improving community relations done
everyone loves the police it's
embarrassing way off all right damn step
aside I got this Captain what about the
Halloween Heist I'll just come in and
win it and then go back to my house damn
it I'm out Jake all right fine sir do
you know why I love coming to work
because there's a bumper pool table in
the breaker room yes obviously I love
the bumper pool table but do you want to
know another reason why
you you've made me a better cop you've
made me a better person I've learned so
much from you so you can't quit because
I need you
how selfish that little speech you just
gave it was all about you and what you
need how unbelievably selfish okay well
I don't want to get mad right now
because I know Amy's worried about you
ah no screw that noise
dare you called Jake selfish he just
wasted his entire honeymoon trying to
take care of you while you wallowed in
your misery like a little baby that
seems a little harsh
I don't give a hoot slow down for the
last five years all I've done is give a
hoot about you and what you think Gabe
who'd about you as a boss gave a hoot
about you as a mentor I gave a hoot
about you as a friend she gave so many
Hoots not anymore after the way you've
acted and what you just said to Jake I
don't give a who what you think and I
really don't give a hoot if you decide
to quit the NYPD so do it I'm all out of
hoot I'm hopeless
now what I want to say is Jake coming
Holly Janeiro
that's all you prepped yeah I just
searched my heart and then wrote down
how I was feeling I'm Gonna Eat You
Alive you dumb son of a cool and
then we'll have kids together yeah it's
gonna be great okay the topic today is
whether or not we should have children I
will be taking the affirmative you'll be
taking the negative each round will be
individually scored by our judge Captain
Holt do you need to hear my credentials
debate moderator license D is in Delta
eight one zero I believe or why isn't
Yankee 4-1 J as in Juliet J as in Julie
at six great I have a variety of timers
do you prefer a buzzer date don't care
ding okay Peralta you can present the
first argument from your uh
scribble list of feelings I'll have you
know that I have some data driven
arguments as well according to a study I
read people with kids were less likely
to report that they were happy in their
lives than people without kids now call
me crazy but being happy tends to make
me feel a pretty happy where did you
read the study well it wasn't something
I read so much as
told about and who told you about it
Hitchcock that's used like a pretty
intellectual thing for him to mention
what was the context he had invested in
an ubering competitor called Badger plug
and was practicing his sales pitch on me
this is your first argument your opening
statement point to Amy all right fine
forget the study I just don't want to
lose what we already have ask anyone
with children and they'll tell you
children bring meaning and love into
your life yes there may be some moments
that you lose but they'll also be new
moments take the water park I would
never go with you but you know who would
your kid
point to Amy that's not your call to
make Peralta point to Amy okay fine new
subject work we both work way too much
why bother having kids if you never get
to spend time with them I mean I love my
job and I know you love yours and I
don't think it's fair for either of us
to have to sacrifice that do you know
why I want to become Lieutenant so badly
to prove your risk to your
hyper-judgmental parents yes obviously
that but also the higher your rank the
more control over your hours plenty of
people have jobs and kids Jake and they
find a way this has become more about
your employment status as your
supervisor I feel I have a conflict of
interest and should abstain from judging
okay so do we both get a point no Kevin
has been on the phone all this time he's
also a licensed to debate moderator
okay fine you want to know why I really
don't want to have children
I had a crappy dad
I know what happens when you mess up as
a parent it's not great and this may
come as a shock to you but
I kind of have some dad issues with
certain people yeah but not just him
it's every male authority figure for my
entire life Hey Jake can you move
Legends of the Fall From new releases to
drama you got it dad Craig was only six
weeks older than me since this has
become about me I'm gonna have to
abstain from this round as well but
Kevin is still standing by actually I
feel as though your personal
relationship with Peralta affects me too
luckily I had Gail standing by as well
oh my God you guys know Gail who's Gail
vice president of the
internet this is a very big deal
no no more credentials please I don't
want to have a structured debate it's an
idiotic way to decide something what I'm
seriously
reporting this